what's going on reject nation i was on
the phone with my buddy aaron
where uh we were just catching up i just
bought dinners about to go eat with my
girlfriend
oh hey a wondervision trailer came out
an hour ago like what
how did i miss this i didn't had no idea
i was like i thought i was done for the
day we got the boys up tenant discussion
up so there's this one division trailer
out probably for
emmys or something right that makes
sense anywho enough chit chat
let's get to it
[Music]
this is our home now i want us to fit in
oh this is going to be how neat where
did you two move from
how long have you been married and why
don't you have children no way
story i think what my wife means to say
is that we moved for
move from where married when damn it why
oh arthur stop it stop it
stop it
[Music]
why would you think that because you are
steven
we are an unusual couple you know oh i
don't think that was ever in question
[Music]
is there a release date ah just coming
soon damn
yeah that looks fantastic it looks like
everything i wanted it to be
all right so i'm not the most
knowledgeable when it comes to
anything really necessarily relating to
either scarlet witch
or vision i heard this is based on the
house of m storyline i heard monica
rambo is in this show and is this girl
or this actress here is that
her can you guys confirm that for me
catherine hahn i'm excited that she's
gonna be in this series and i'm just
gonna keep this short this is giving me
everything that i wanted it to be
it feels very weird bizarre zany
it has a whole bunch of different tones
that i'm already loving because i really
love
like the homage vibe to the classic
television shows that looks great
feels very cerebral and trippy and it
kind of gives me
sort of a vibe of the little bits i've
seen of legion
mixed with a hint of the good side of
ryan murphy because when i say that ryan
murphy touch
i'm kind of thinking about how it has
this
comedic self-aware vibe but it also
looks like it can have some moments
where it starts feeling
a bit like a horror movie like that
moment where catherine hahn says because
you're also dead or whatever that gave
me chills man there was something about
that that felt very
tense and there's something there's
elements here that i imagine can feel
a little nightmarish in terms of i know
i know
one thing you shouldn't do is bring up
dc when you're talking about something
marvel related what i've been loving
that what dc's been doing with their
television shows
specifically doom patrol is how bonkers
it is how trippy and strange and weird
it is looking at this
it feels very separate from the style
and what we've kind of grown used to
with the mcu generally
offers not saying always i'm saying
generally offers what we got here
this feels absolutely bonkers and i love
that now i think some of us
were wondering okay will this feel like
a a marvel movie
on a streaming service or will it feel
like a tv show
and right now it feels like a tv show
which is a good thing that's a great
thing i don't want that to sound like
i'm diminishing the quality here because
obviously disney plus has got that
money they got that marvel money so like
the production looks great but to make a
tv show where you can really
dive into these characters who didn't
get the full on treatment
that you could with character
exploration on the big screen now you
can get it with them here on this tv
show and on top of that
this is the chance they can take the
opportunity to really get experimental
to the max
i really hope they really i really hope
they commit full-heartedly to doing some
things that we've never seen the mcu do
and i want it to get weird all right
guys what did you think about this
trailer
leave your thoughts down below this
looked awesome
thank you guys so much give all the
explanations to me of every little
little nugget or hint or you know
whatever predictions you got
down below and i love seeing elizabeth
olsen dance in her classic scarlet witch
outfit that was really amusing
[Music]
you